the French government will force
controversial pension reforms through
without a vote in Parliament after
failing to convince a majority of MPS to
back the bill let's look at the live
pictures from Paris right now where
protesters have gathered outside
Parliament upon hearing the news the
changes will raise the retirement age
from 62 to 64. president Emmanuel macron
says this is essential to cover pension
deficits but there's been widespread
opposition to his plan millions of
people have taken part in protests and
marches and Strikes across France
Natasha Butler has more on this from
Paris
the day started with the French
government hoping to put this proposed
pension reform Bill to a vote but they
simply didn't know whether they'd get
enough support from some opposition MPS
in order for this bill to pass and as
that was the case they decided to push
it through by decree it's not a total
surprise it was a little bit in the air
in the last few days it was a course of
action that the government might have
taken and have obviously decided to take
now nevertheless it will be seen by many
as a failure of Politics as a failure of
president macron to really convince
people about a reform that has proved to
be let's face it unpopular some
two-thirds of French people up to three
quarters sometimes in opinion polls say
that they are against this reform
because they see it as unfair an erosion
of social rights and erosion of the
French social model and from macro's
point of view he says look the pension
reforms the pension system in France is
complex it is out of date it costs too
much money it is not sustainable for
future Generations that is why it needs
to be modernized he also says people are
living longer these days therefore they
can work longer and it would bring the
French pension system more into line
with other countries in Western Europe
but people don't feel the same you know
we've seen that on the streets over the
past two months the strikes in the
protests and we've been speaking to
protesters there were some behind me
they've dispersed now but they were
saying they will continue with protests
and Strikes in the coming days because
they're very angry very upset that this
bill has gone through
Excel person is General Secretary of the
cgt union for Railway workers he joins
us from the Parisian suburb of trap he's
live with us on the program
um thank you for joining us what do you
make of the government having to resort
to what's known in France is the 49-3
which is the measure that allows them to
bypass a vote in Parliament what do you
make of that
okay well it shows that not only does
the government it doesn't have a
majority amongst the public opinion
amongst the working people and it
doesn't even have a majority in its own
Parliament which really shows that no
one except for the government and the
employers wants this reform to be
implemented and it has no Democratic
legitimacy we already knew that from
different opinion polls and also from
the discussions we had in all the
workplaces so this attack has no
Democratic legitimacy and we will
continue to fight it and as such the
strike and the struggle will continue
tomorrow and we will try to convince all
our fellow workers to pursue the strikes
that have begun on the 7th of March and
we are determined not only to block the
the the bill to be enforced that we will
also continue the fight in order to
defeat this government and force it to
back down completely and maintain our
current pensions as they exist and of
course we will always be available for
negotiations that aim to improve them
but not any negotiations that would aim
to destroy or deteriorate rate the
conditions at which we retire or the
amount of pension we get
so that's the grand Spirits so French
governments I understand you are against
bypassing the vote in Parliament but
French governments are allowed to do
this it is legal So when you say you
want to block it how do you intend to do
that
well as we did the last pension reform
that they tried to implement was in 2019
actually they tried it uh four uh three
years ago I'm sorry and we went on
strike for like 56 days and eventually
actually the the the parliament actually
voted it through well it didn't vote
they used the 49-3 article in the
Constitution which allows them to
enforce it without a vote in Parliament
and eventually they had to withdraw that
bill that was never implemented then
covet happened the first lockdowns
happened and the government and the
tourists chose not to relaunch the legal
procedure to enforce it anymore and
chose to abandon it we have loads of
laws in French labor history that have
been voted through even sometimes uh the
decrees that were necessary for them to
be enforced had been published but the
organized labor managed to uh to defeat
it so you're saying essentially that you
want to harden the protests and the
strike movement so that it raises the
political cost for the president and he
eventually throws in the towel is that
what you're saying
not only the political cost but also the
economical cost because behind the
government uh is also uh he's acting on
behalf of the interest of the employers
and the big corporations and uh as such
we are therefore organizing strikes
which aim of course to raise the
political cost for him but also the
economical path to force the employers
to call him and tell him to back off
because basically by telling him this is
not worth it just uh just give up so
that's why we're on strike today the
supporters of President macron the
people who voted for him would probably
tell you well they voted for him on this
platform of reforming and he did win the
election promising to reform pensions
amongst other things
well as you know winning an election is
one thing but it doesn't necessarily
equate with representing the will of the
majority because for several reasons for
example there are several people who are
on strike today and who are
demonstrating who voted for Eminem for
example in the second round not because
they supported his uh his pension law
but because they for example wanted to
not uh be uh presided by the far right
and many of his voters voted not by
choice but more as a default as a way to
prevent the far right from Gaining power
and uh I don't and we don't really care
what workers voted or not regardless of
what we voted uh even if you voted for
macron the far right the far left
whatever we will all be attacked and
forced to work another additional two
years if we don't manage to defeat it
and it is it is in none of our interests
and all the opinion polls show that the
support for our strike is very high it's
about 60 in the general population but
if we narrow it down to working people
of workers in France oppose this uh this
attack and the experiences as a brutal
attack on their living standards and
living conditions
General Secretary of the cgt union for
Railway workers thank you for joining us
on the program
thank you